how do you stay positive having seen the
absolute worst in humanity easy I have a
beautiful brunette I'm gonna do a huge
alliteration here beautiful brunette
busty babe that's bangin in a bikini
that will drink bourbon with me yeah
boom yeah so yeah
I have heard kids and women scream that
I threw a grenade into the room they're
having their dad shoot from get
nightmares from it
yeah I've seen dock donkeys go down
wells because the village lied to us
yeah I've watched bombs get dropped on
entire villages where I knew that there
are people like not bad people there are
good people near bad people and watch to
all the buildings crumble I love life I
love my wife I love my kids I love a
sunset I appreciate art I play the piano
I wish I could appreciate beer don't
have a palate for it but like everything
about life is that much sweeter because
I know how nasty and ugly it is and at
any point I forgot why I fight and I
forgot what right was and I forgot what
humanity is I'm done the moment where I
was like I want to go kill something I'm
good at it I'm good at war there's
nothing else I'm good at and there's
that temptation because you're good at
something you want to go do more of it
to go and spend time doing that if I
ever had that that realization that I'm
actually doing that I'm done
i turn my gun in I'd go be a Salesman I
draw it sell Kia's I don't care now that
I'm talking smack about TIA Kia's I'm
just or a Hyundai whatever
and this is a subject that comes up that
I think people want to understand in the
civilian world and you've definitely
nailed a perspective that I think most
guys feel and I would say on top of that
is that war while it does expose you to
the worst part of humanity in my mind
forever I will I don't think I will ever
see anything as moving or as beautiful
as men rolling out into a horrible place
day after day night after night risking
their lives directly indirectly for
their country for the civilians that are
there that they're trying to protect and
for each other now and to to go to
memorial service after memorial service
and realize that these are and again you
know I always trying to remind everybody
that listens to this that but when I say
memorial service I'm not talking about a
dog tag and and some body in a uniform
I'm talking about a kid talking about a
person and a person that sacrificed
everything in in everything everything
they are and everything they ever will
be and so you
war will show you the worst part of
humanity but that right there is an
incredible part of humanity and I don't
care about the politics of it I don't
care about any of that but you're
talking about men that will give their
lives for their friends and when I have
that in the back of my mind then that
makes it very easy for me to stay
positive and very easy for me to wake up
in the morning and say I'm gonna do my
damnedest today to live a good life and
do some good things and trying to honor
those guys so I don't think war makes
you worse I think war makes you better
those services those memorials they're
not like just some dude had a young
young SF guy died and his wife was like
you know why don't you bring him back to
me
you know Joe it's like to lose him you
know do you know what we had you know
you didn't know him I was like bitch
please I didn't I sat there and took it
you know like what do you what do you
think we sit there and talk about as
we're staring at a tree for 12 hours
yeah you know I know what your farts
smell like woman you know I know what
his favorite panties were on you you
know I know every single kid name event
other your kids when their birthday is
you know you don't think you think you
know him better than I know him how much
time did you spend with him in the past
five years you know day and night 60
hours straight taking his blood you know
being covered in it like we know like
this isn't just some memorial you know
we need to sacrifice that you're talking
about it's there's a different level of
you know talk about intimacy the
brothers and when we say it's about the
dude standing next to us
it's the dirt it's not just subdued you
know it's not some cliche line in a
movie yeah
like these are dudes when we say it
would die for him it's for a reason it's
because we've no-one ever known somebody
that close and never will forever and
they're the best dudes on the planet
yeah you're right over there uncle
Charlie yeah kind of used to do when he
starts talking I'm just like what is the
next word there's too much space because
I can't take it anymore
shit dude